so if work is key from everything for
our folks with intellectual disabilities
for those in recovery to those fleeing
domestic violence how is it that it
suddenly becomes controversial when we
turn to welfare programs to ask Work
Ready adults to work train or volunteer
to receive their welfare benefits how is
that morally wrong or controversial I
worry about a country in which you say
to a child that they shall go hungry
because their parent can't find a job
has particular challenges I do not think
we need to do that in a country as great
as ours welcome to the Silla Forum a
monthly Oxford style debate series that
features topics of special interest to
libertarians thanks to the Smith Family
Foundation for making this series
possible we're live at the subculture
Theatre in New York City but it also
like to welcome our online audience for
the live stream I'm Jean Epstein an
economic journalist and the director and
moderator of the so forum here's how
tonight's debate will work the audience
initially votes a four against or
undecided on the resolution and you can
do that now by going to soho vote.com
Soh ovo t.com so vote comm there you'll
see the resolution and you'll be able to
vote for or against we'll be closing the
voting in a few minutes so please vote
now on livestream at the end of the
debate you'll have a chance to vote
again and whoever moves the needle in
his or her favor
is to clear the winner tonight's
resolution is as follows 15 million
able-bodied adults on government welfare
would have a better chance at economic
benefit betterment if they were taken
off welfare one more time 15 million
able-bodied adults on government welfare
would have a better chance at economic
betterment if they were taken off
welfare
so get your votes in now also for the
audience at home submit your questions
in the comments and we'll pick a couple
to read out loud
during the Q&A session now on to the
event defending to nice resolution we
have Taryn Brogdon president and CEO of
the foundation for government
accountability Taryn please come to the
stage opposing the resolution we have
Neera tanden president and CEO of the
Center for American Progress
Neera please come to the stage we are
now closing the voting okay
Taryn you have 12 minutes to defend the
resolution 15 million able-bodied adults
on government welfare would have a
better chance at economic betterment if
they were taken off welfare ticket away
Taryn this summer I met del a young man
from Cuba he risked his life traveling
from Cuba to Miami three years ago in a
small boat with 13 others many of those
13 died he swam two miles to shore as
that boat sank he did all that he risked
his life to work in America and in just
three short years he's experiencing
America to the fullest
he completed technical school he got
married he has a child and he's now
working in construction and as soon as
he set foot on this land of opportunity
he started realizing his potential
he's living an American dream
and his children will never have to risk
their lives to live the dream as well
growing up I had not an uncle who never
worked they were both born in America
but tragically they chose to trade the
lifetime of opportunity for the
certainty of monthly welfare but free
government and Welfare cash assistance
free government food free government
health care came at a high price my aunt
died in her 50s and as I sat at her
funeral I thought of what might have
been she had so much to offer she was
born in America but she her husband and
her daughters were trapped in a lifetime
of dependency for decades they lived on
an island of despair surrounded by
welfare and no work two people one
America but two vastly different
outcomes one risked his life to travel
from despair to opportunity another born
an opportunity but lived in despair and
without hope it didn't have to be that
way I want you to think about your first
job for pay mine was actually cleaning
out the cow stalls in my parents barn
and now I work in politics and a same
job different shovel but whether it was
my first job or every job after work
gave me new experiences and it showed me
the possibilities in myself
does welfare do that I think it does the
opposite you want the simple truth
welfare is so destructive because it
pays people not to work and so they
don't and they remain in dependency and
poverty for a very long time
I founded the foundation for government
accountability because I've seen
firsthand what America has to offer and
the power of work both in my own life
and in others
and the tragedy of misguided government
welfare programs our experts have
testified in 30 states before numerous
committees both the US House and Senate
commissioned over a hundred public
opinion polls and our reforms have been
passed now in 34 different states and
those reforms mean that literally
millions of Americans will move from
welfare to work and on to a better life
first I want to make sure we're on the
same page about a few things this debate
is about as Jean said able-bodied adults
of working age on welfare people who are
between 18 and 64 years old it's not
about those with disabilities it's not
about kids or the elderly it's not even
about adults whom social workers or
doctors say are unable to work whatever
the physical or mental health reason
might be it's about people who can go to
work tomorrow but do not able-bodied
think work ready and when I talk about
welfare I'm talking about able-bodied
adults who receive welfare cash
assistance food stamps and or Medicaid
I'm not talking about Social Security or
Medicare there are at least 15 million
adults in America who fit this
definition and are on at least one major
welfare program it's nearly record high
welfare enrollment right now at the same
time we have near record low
unemployment in most places so who are
these able-bodied adults well most are
white most are under 35 nearly half are
men and most do not have young children
at home that's a problem welfare used to
be this program that was targeted
towards the truly needy very poor
children those with disabilities may be
the and also the frail and poor elderly
and none of us in this room would debate
the importance of a government safety
net for the truly needy I support those
programs but able-bodied adults on
welfare should have to work train or
volunteer to receive their welfare
benefits a long-term worker trained 20
hours a week or volunteer about 40 hours
a month
why 97 and 16 what if I told you about a
program that ensured that 97% of people
on it would be out of poverty
would you support it do you know what
that program is any full-time job 97% of
people who work full-time are out of
poverty it's true yet only 16% of
able-bodied adults on Medicaid do work
full-time just one in six and the
majority report no earnings at all I
think we'd all agree that people are
better off going to work
look welfare is not terrible but it is
terrible if it keeps people from working
and what's better what's the best way to
help people move from welfare to work
it's to require them to work train or
volunteer and do you know why I know
that's true we studied it we actually
tracked 60,000 people impacted by work
requirements in two states not just some
of them all of them we tracked parents
and childless adults all of them
able-bodied we tracked folks on food
stamps as well as those on cash
assistance and we found an inspiring
outcome before work requirements and
these programs only a portion of
individuals worked see it's not enough
to want to work we all need a push and a
deadline but after work requirements
most went to work right away incomes of
those working doubled over time and aunt
average income of those working were
above the poverty limit within 12 months
and welfare enrollment for these
individuals dropped an astounding 75 to
90 percent with a work requirement
people are on welfare for just a short
period of time and their human faces to
this success take Jason he signed up for
food stamps in 2009 just as the Great
Recession was hitting but there he
remained for four years
no job no income just welfare 1705 days
but when Kansas implemented the work
requirement Jason was among the first to
leave and in just over three months he
got a job in the publishing industry
making forty five thousand dollars a
year with Jason bad or wrong because he
was on welfare
no but welfare was wrong and bad because
it kept Jason trapped by keeping him at
home and away from his next job or take
Amanda she was stuck on the program
since nineteen ninety three nineteen
ninety three she signed up for food
stamps just a few months before Bill
Clinton's inauguration nearer might
remember Hilary's husband for seven
thousand five hundred and seventy nine
days Amanda was trapped in dependency
but with the right policy in place she
quickly found a job and worked her way
out of poverty and you know what there
was the most interesting thing we found
we wondered if folks would move
essentially from welfare to Walmart but
nothing could be further from the truth
individuals moved into six hundred
different industries six hundred
different industries less than five
percent actually went into general
retail or Walmart type stores many in
health care construction technical
positions in fact one in five started in
a temp job and then often moved into
permanent employment consider this other
fact in Texas do you know how long a
single mom on welfare cash assistance is
on the program as she meets the work
requirement twenty two days that's right
just three weeks if she's meeting the
work requirement work is so much more
than a paycheck whose future would you
bet on a woman working a few hours and
taking home a hundred dollars or a guy
not working at all and receiving that
same hundred dollars in food stamps
who's more likely to get more hours
another shift or a new job who feels
better at the end of a day but the true
cost is not about the taxpayer spending
the true cost is the money not reaching
the truly needy
let me explain at the same time we have
near-record welfare enrollment for
able-bodied adults we have 600,000
Americans with intellectual and
developmental disabilities as well as
frail kids and elderly on waiting lists
for key medicaid services because when
you take a dollar away
oh I'm sorry when you take a dollar and
give it to those choosing not to work
you take a dollar away from those
waiting lists from cops kids or roads
here's one of them not long after birth
a rare neurological condition for Skylar
Overman onto Arkansas's medicaid waiting
list there she would wait for nearly ten
years
she was immobile and relies fully on her
family for the help medicaid provides
and from the beginning her mother
Lindsay fought for her daughter to get
life-saving services and medication but
she's still on that waiting list and
there are more than 3000 like Skylar
waiting in Arkansas alone America is a
rich country but our nation's wealth is
only as strong as the people working to
support it and this debate is not about
what can we afford it's about the cost
to people's lives when they're trapped
on welfare and in despair and don't
experience the power of work and the
cost to those were not serving like
Skylar my father grew up in dysfunction
and my mother grew up in a family
wrecked by alcohol I'm number five of
eight kids and like naira
I'm the direct beneficiary of parents
who worked hard to overcome the
challenges they faced or were born into
but that better life and the opportunity
we both enjoy came as a direct result of
their love and support but also as a
direct outcome of the hard work
employment and opportunity they created
don't we owe the same thing for those 15
million able-bodied adults trapped on
welfare thank you
you're attending 12:12 minutes to speak
against the resolution take it away Mira
Thanks thank you I wanna thank Jean
Epstein for inviting me and it's great
to be here we have all of you I
appreciate the opportunity to speak up
to say Who form and I'm really enjoy I
hope I really enjoy the sparring with
Iran I guess I would just say um you
know at the essence if we're having an
argument about work and the value of
work I guess I would say I totally agree
Tarun that work is an incredibly
important value and I do think that we
should respect work more in our society
what I disagree with fundamentally is a
conflation of
people who've received support with
those who aren't working the true
challenge in our society today in my
view is that we have the growing crisis
of the working poor Tarun conflates
three different programs TANF Medicaid
and food stamps I understand why he
conflates this but one of those are
traditionally considered welfare
Temporary Assistance for Needy Families
Medicaid and food stamps basically
addressed two issues that people need
health care and food at the end of the
day we only have two and a half million
Americans on TANF today not fifteen
million two and a half million Americans
on TANF today we passed TANF in the
mid-1990s Democrats and Republicans came
together to pass that bill both said it
would end poverty it has not poverty has
actually grown since the 1990s the TANF
program has not ended poverty in America
it has ended the welfare caseloads that
it has not actually ended poverty I
think
our goal should be to move people out of
poverty I'm willing to look at
conservative answers that are liberal
answers of that for that but I think we
should be crystal clear about what Taryn
is talking about today the TANF program
were only operates for people who have
children there are no childless adults
using TANF or what most people call
welfare the Medicaid program vast
majority of people in the Medicaid
program have children many many of them
are working food stamps I think we do
have a problem that a working people are
forced to use with food stamps that's a
challenge I see that challenge as one in
which working people don't have a
livable wage to afford food because my
basic principle difference here is that
I think we should not say people in
America should go hungry Taryn thinks
they should I guess he thinks that you
know if they go hungry for a while
that'll incentivize them not to go
hungry but let's be clear about some
global facts the United States provides
less social service benefits than most
countries in the OECD that's a choice
we've made it is not the case that our
labor force participation is greater
than most countries in the OECD
in fact many countries with a much
stronger welfare state have a much
higher labor force participation rate
all the Nordic countries Germany all
these countries have a higher labor
force participation rate if Taryn was
right that a weak welfare state meant
higher labor force participation that
would not be true we would in fact have
the highest labor force participation
rate we do not
I think the true challenge in the United
States is one in which we unfortunately
have a lot of people who work make
minimum wage and can't make ends meet
and that is what the that is what
essentially food stamps and the Medicaid
program are about they are working
people who don't have access to health
care Taryn says if you're working and
poor you shouldn't have health care if
your employer doesn't provide it that's
his right to say I think that is not a
principle that supports work it's not
expanding work to say we're gonna get
rid of healthcare for people who are
working people who make who are working
day in and day out do not have access to
health care in the United States and
that is what the Medicaid program is
about and the Medicaid expansion I will
note that he he referenced a study that
he did that his organization did in
around the Kansas program some people
have criticized that study Peter Grannis
who is a conservative who worked for the
Bush administration and others who said
that the that there were flaws with that
study but particularly it has said
nothing about reducing poverty these are
not programs that reduce poverty or the
work he's done or not do not help reduce
poverty I do think in the United States
we should do more to ensure that work
pays that means making sure and
supporting programs where work will pay
more so if people don't have to work a
full time job and be on food stamps to
ensure their children don't go hungry I
think that is a terrible thing in the
United States but it happens it happens
all the time you could argue that we're
being too generous to the single mom who
works at Walmart and uses food stamps to
make
her two kids are got not going hungry I
do not think we are being too generous
fact I think as a country we should
think about how we can encourage work to
pay a wage where people can raise their
families I
I agree I believe we should have a
stronger and higher minimum wage that
way
governments wouldn't have to subsidize
families who are working but
libertarians have traditionally opposed
that and move the minimum wage in the
United States today is $7.25 an hour I
think if you think work should pay
perhaps we should move off of some of
those perspectives I will say that I
completely appreciate the perspective of
the parents terrons uncle I hear the
concern about Terrans
uncle and not staying at home and not
working but today if you if you don't
have kids or even if you do have kids
you get a lifetime limit on on TANF and
you were done there is no there are not
places here where you can be on welfare
for the rest of your life not working
that does not exist that was ended what
Aaron's really talking about when he
says dependency is food stamps in the
Medicaid program and I'll say I was
actually I grew up on welfare my mother
and my father got divorced my father
left I had every benefit you can you we
were talking about today my mother got
on back then it was AFDC my my father
left we were homeless we basically moved
into an apartment that was subsidized
with section 8 housing I was on food
stamps we were on food stamps I had free
and reduced lunch my mom had never
worked a day in her life and eventually
within a couple of years
got a job as a travel agent and we went
off all of those programs but Iowa side
of this programs not for my mom alone
but for me as a child to make sure that
I had real opportunity my mom was able
to get an apartment we lived in a nice
we lived in in Bedford Massachusetts
which had good public schools I within a
couple of years she was able to get on
her feet and move into a house she you
know so many ways is the American dream
if you said to her that there were no
food stamps or new Medicaid when her
kids were five and ten
you just have hungry kids you just have
kids you'd go sick I don't think that's
the right strategy for the country I
think we should think together about how
we can make work pay for everyone I do
not think we have an epidemic of people
just staying at home living on welfare
because welfare doesn't exist anymore
all there is is food stamps and health
care for people
there's no way to pay for a roof over
your head forever none of these things
exist anymore
there's there's times you can do that
but there is a lifetime limit and it is
it is not generous in many parts of the
country so I look forward to an engaged
debate on these topics I hope we can
actually talk about the millions of
people who are actually working day to
day and struggling to make ends meet
because to me that is the moral
challenge of our time thank you
now in five minutes of rebuttal you can
take the podium good it's great to have
this conversation
start out by saying first work is not a
punishment work is an opportunity and I
think narrow points out to two different
things that are important to recognize
one we took these principles of welfare
reform and work requirements and applied
them to one program welfare cash
assistance enrollment in that program
has dropped by about two-thirds as
individuals have to work trained or
volunteer to get back into the workforce
as quickly as possible
you heard the stat in Texas that a woman
a single mom because that's the most of
who's on welfare cash assistance will
move back to work and off the program if
she's meeting that work trainer
volunteer requirement in 22 days what's
happened though is rather than apply
those same lessons to two other major
welfare programs food stamps for
able-bodied adults and Medicaid for
able-bodied adults we've turned our back
on that lesson to see what's the
quickest and most efficient way to get
somebody back to work there are more
people on food stamps today than the
entire population of Canada it's up from
just 17 million Americans in the year
2000 that's not the definition of
success that's the definition of failure
but yet at the same time as she admits
we know what works and what fails when
it comes to welfare it's the requirement
of work train or volunteer get engaged
back into the community as quickly as
possible so the individuals can
transition off welfare and then get out
of poverty as quickly as possible it's
interesting because you're trying to
have it both ways on one hand you say
that people on welfare already work and
therefore a work requirement is not
needed
well the USDA which oversees food stamps
report
that a majority of able-bodied adults on
food stamps have no earned income and
only a minority are working at all and a
small minority of working full-time same
is true for able-bodied adults on
Medicaid a majority have no earned
income so it's simply not true and yet
at the same time you say that if we put
into place this work requirement work
trainer volunteer that it would be
harmful for individuals well both
statements can't be true it can't be
that everyone's working so you don't
need a work requirement and yet if you
had one it would be harmful here are the
facts
these aren't made-up these are directly
from USDA two out of every five
able-bodied adults on food stamps have
been there at least eight years two
thousand nine hundred days and yet we
know that getting somebody to work full
time is the best the quickest and the
most assured way to get them out of
poverty and yet at the same time that we
have near-record welfare enrollment for
able-bodied adults in these two programs
food stamps and Medicaid we also have
today six and a half million open jobs
in America I think it's odd that
regardless of political ideology in
almost every other area there's
consensus on the value of work for folks
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities work as a key goal in fact
in Washington State 86% of adults with
these disabilities are working or in
substance abuse individuals who work
while in treatment have higher rates of
success in recovery I'm going to read a
quote to you effective recovery then
this is from addiction calm effective
recovery almost always involves an
individual having gainful employment
finding and keeping a job and making a
contribution to society through his or
her efforts the piece goes on to list 14
different benefits of work work is also
key in a domestic-violence situation so
that a woman can break free knowing she
can support herself and her children
away from her abuser
I saw it firsthand with my own sister
so if work is key from everything for
our folks with intellectual disabilities
for those in recovery to those fleeing
domestic violence how is it that it
suddenly becomes controversial when we
turn to welfare programs to ask Work
Ready adults to work train or volunteer
to receive their welfare benefits how is
that morally wrong or controversial work
is much more than a paycheck people who
work have better health better mental
health higher rates of happiness and
lower rates of depression smoking and
obesity like Jason and Amanda that I
talked to you about there are millions
trapped in dependency who deserve their
own success story let's agree that in
2018 success will be defined by how many
move from welfare to work thank you
I'm sorry brother Sameera I guess I'll
just uh clarify some of the points I
think that we're talking a little bit
past each other because when you talk
about snap a lot of the people who are
taking up snack or snap or children and
elderly disabled or in a working
household in fact four out of every five
people who take part and snap are one of
those categories children elderly
disabled or already in a working
household the thing we're debating truly
today because TANF exists and there's
welfare and there's a work requirement
around TANF is whether there should be
work requirements around Medicaid and
food stamps and I guess my view of this
is pretty simple which is a major Gant
ik believer and work and I really
believe that this nation that people are
just don't want to work and just want to
stay home there's no income for them
other than food stamps and Medicaid but
that's what they want to do I just don't
think that's realistic I've lived on
Benin welfare I know people want to get
off of it what I would say is it's just
my view is
it's not doesn't get anyone a job faster
to take away their food stamps it is not
the case since you're only subsidizing
food you're not giving anyone income the
idea that people are just wanting to be
on food stamps when they have no income
is something that I think our experience
belies - as the employment rate has gone
up food stamps has gone down the food
stamp use is not as at its highest point
it is coming down with the employment
with employment rates going up people
are not staying on food stamps as
incomes rise it has been a program for
people who are struggling it is a
challenge that we have poverty in the
United States I will simply say again if
work requirements ended poverty poverty
would have ended because we have work
requirements think the reality of the
situation we're in as a country is that
we do have a continuing challenge of
poverty there are people who are still
struggling a lot of them are working the
vast majority of poor people in the
United States today are working poor a
work requirement has not ended poverty
for them it still exists the fact that
we have a welfare requirement a workfare
requirement in welfare which has meant
that people spend 22 months in Texas is
simply a tautology you're right people
have to work Valentin so they do the
reality is that in Texas the poverty
rate is higher than in the average in
the United States that has not ended
poverty in Texas my view is I would love
to think through ways to encourage work
and work that pays that I think is
something that actually truly
dresses poverty in the United States the
fact that the minimum wage has not kept
up with inflation for decades is a true
challenge the fact that millions of
Americans work 40 50 60 hours and cannot
make basic ends meet is a real challenge
I think we should really think through
why that is in a country is great as
ours
I can cry believe we should encourage
work and the way to do that is to pay a
livable wage to people the end of the
day I worry about a country and a
community and a family in which you say
to a child that they shall go hungry
because their parent can't find a job
has particular challenges I do not think
we need to do that in a country as great
as ours I think we should celebrate work
by making work pay for all families that
is the best way path out of poverty
liberals and conservatives can believe
can agree that work is at the foundation
of this but health care hunger are
issues that we should say people have a
right to if you're working you see we
still have those challenges that's why
he has a number of 15 million not 2.5
thank you now the yacht is part of you
get it each gets a chance to ask a
question to questions of the other
Tarrant can you go first
do you have a question for Neera
you've been working in this area for 20
years and you made the point that we
should start thinking about what to do
what's the solution for moving those
able-bodied adults the majority of whom
are not working from food stamps and
Medicaid and getting them reengaged and
out of poverty so you recognize that
that 15 million isn't a static number
right so it's not like 15 million people
five years ago and today are the same 15
million people right so those people are
churning so a person today who is on the
Medicaid program who isn't working is
likely as you know from the statistics
is likely to be working in the next
couple of years right so it's not a
number that we've had year in and year
out 15 million people who are on who
aren't working who are in Medicaid or
TANF or food stamps that is a number
that's changed over time so most of
those people are gonna find jobs and
some people many people who have jobs
today are going to lose their job at
some point in the future and then rely
on those programs so I think the 15
million number is a little poor doesn't
give the right impression it's not like
there's 15 million people who've been in
an underclass you've been there year
after year after year they are turning
in and out of work and many of them will
go into work and never come back many of
them will lose a job and stay there for
a while so I think that's the problem
we're trying to solve you have a
question and could you just tell me a
little bit more about your uncle and
aunt who weren't working was that after
the Tanna after AFDC was destroyed and
become TANF okay well I thought you
supported that but maybe I'm confused no
okay well I guess I'm confused because I
thought you said that that was good that
they were
a work requirement now in that program
yeah okay I'm just stating that it was
before and after actually so do they hit
the five-year limit and then end or did
they five-year and at that time I wasn't
enforced what do you mean it was an
enforcement they were giving an
exemption for that limit for the
five-year limit how well what was the
exemption what was the exemption it was
for a variety of they were determined
that for mental health reasons that
would not have to work not a mental
health condition but for mental health
reasons mostly anxiety what state was
that mean because I didn't think that
they had that exemption in me okay
that's interesting though I didn't think
they had a mental health exception is in
Maine since we're making John your
question sure so I guess I have a
question for you as far as considering
the life situations of two men John's on
multiple welfare programs receives about
$500 a month in benefits in the value of
those welfare programs and has chosen
not to work and then you have one who
works part-time and earns $500 a month
in income who do you think's better
positioned for future success so I'm so
confused by this example because is
we've talked about the TANF program is
one in which you have to have children
to to use it the reason that requirement
is there is so that if you should
because we believe as a society that
children shouldn't be punished for the
decisions of their parents so if it's
not that John as a parent
he is a then I think you're just talking
about food stamps and Medicaid so I I
guess I would I'd say is I don't know
many people and we don't have an
experience of a lot
people who have food stamps and use the
Medicaid program which is a health
insurance program for poor people most
again most of whom are working who they
don't have any income coming in so you
know I think most of those people are
trying to work so you don't believe the
federal data that a majority have no
reported income able-bodied adults who
are on food stamps or Medicaid well I've
seen this is a that you raise this and
this is very confusing point because
according to our data and oh looks ruied
is that the SNAP program food stamp
program which you're right is in serving
around 40 million people they have ever
there as I said elderly children
disabled working person in the family
four out of five snap recipients there
are we do not have a lot of experience
with millions of food stamp recipients
who were able-bodied live in a household
by themselves working and making like a
decent wage because obviously they
couldn't I will say if someone's making
minimum wage has two kids can't feed
their family it's hard you know you're a
single mom you have two kids we're
talking about forty one dollars and a
day and in take-home pay forty one
dollars a day to pay rent to pay for
food to pay for everything else I feel
I'm like I think it's okay if you're
working and you need to use food stamps
or if you have a disability for a while
and use food stamps to make sure your
kids don't go hungry okay we're gonna be
lining up to ask questions meanwhile get
to the mic and ask a question but I mean
while I want to take moderators
prerogative to ask a question of each
side Taryn I want to start with you
could you go a little bit more into
those 15 million my puzzles are first
the question that nura raised
the turnover are you know are all 15
million of them you know do we have a
new 15 million every few months I would
suspect that that of those 15 million
dollar a number of them a fair share who
are pretty permanently in that situation
but then my related questions what
situation are you talking about they are
are they not on TANF how many of them on
TANF which mean they have children and
then they're not on TANF but they're
only on food stamps and Medicaid then
how do they pay their bills otherwise I
want to suggest that possibly they don't
have reported income because they're
working in the underground economy and
that they actually are working maybe
producing something good maybe pushing
drugs who knows but could you could you
break down a little bit more sorry for
the complex question that 15 million
that you speak of or able-bodied who
should be working yeah the 15 million
able-bodied adults are adults that are
either on the food stamp program who
mayor they're able-bodied working-age no
disabilities and a social worker or a
doctor have determined that they can
work so we're talking about able-bodied
by anyone's definition an error brings
in disabled children elderly I
specifically said in my opening we're
not talking about that in fact the
report you cite of that a majority of
individuals on food stamps are working
is from the early 2000s when there was a
work requirement in place for childless
adults on food stamps and the USDA has
taken down that research off its website
because it's inaccurate and out of date
that was when the program was below 20
million today it's over 40 million about
43 million so we're talking about adults
who are on that program
there's over 15 million of them on food
stamps there's about 22 million who meet
that definition who are on Medicaid so
so you're saying so in other words you
are you are simply saying then that just
one specific statistic is that of the
approximately 43 million people who are
on food stamps
the data about them from the USDA the
administers the program is that 15
million of those 43 million I do not
have reported income that's all the 15
million are able-bodied adults of
working age on a majority of them do not
have reported income and as you heard me
mention about forty percent have been on
the program for eight years longer okay
and that's strictly that's strictly the
food stamp is what's called the SNAP
program that's strictly a food stamp
number that you're basing that on and
but then but then a related question how
do you think they mean you can't you
can't put food up on the roof how do
they live otherwise do you think I think
there's some that are working in the
underground economy I I think that
what's interesting from the studies of
the work requirement going into the
place is the individuals had an
opportunity to work trained or volunteer
in order to continue to receive their
benefit what happened was a majority
went to work right away so a small
portion were working before that a
majority went to work right away
and about 60% went to work over the next
year and so I think what you see is a
difference in either they move from
unreported income to reported income
through a job and the visible economy or
individuals who were making ends meet in
some way suddenly go back to work in
record numbers which is what the data
shows and again this isn't some sample
this is 60,000 individuals in multiple
programs in multiple states yes okay but
you're saying 40% of that 15 million
there are eight year there on the air
plan at least so to speak but do you
have a comment on that yeah I'll just
say a few things first of all the report
I was using firfer out of every five US
from the Center on Budget and Policy
Priorities which was sanctioned by the
USDA and it's from I believe five years
ago not from the early 2000s no I'm
sorry three years ago not the early
2000s nearly 73 percent of the American
of Americans received some form of
government assistance such as Medicaid
snap and TANF
members of working families so that you
know I do think that the vast majority
of people and these programs are working
and I would say I just you're not
actually addressing the issue obviously
a lot of people on food stamps have been
on food stamps for a long time who are
working working poor people are on food
stamps so it's not that you know you're
right a lot of people have been on food
stamps for a long time the question I
that I think you were asking we're about
the 15 million number and whether that
is a static number and it is not it is
not the is not the same group of people
five years ago as today they're that
number a lot of as I said a lot of
people and that number had worked and
lost a job and didn't you know we chose
to not rescind their Medicaid when they
lost a job or their food stamps when
they lost a job a lot of people a lot of
people today you you know who are doing
fine will be that group in the future
you're challenging if I hear correctly
correct leader he's claiming a 43
million 15 million which of course is
not a majority by any means a little
over a third of 15 million are listed by
the USDA as not having gainful
employment and and of those 15 million
about 40 percent have been on food
stamps for for eight years so that
therefore so do you question those
particular numbers I'm sorry I think
that eight million who've been on
government who've been on food stamps
for eight years are not in the 50
million I don't think that's right we
have a disagreement in facts
disagreement on the facts which will
have to record Brittney's do you do it
my question to you then your it would be
if I wanted to ask you a particular
question but I want to follow up on this
issue of facts with respect to the
Terrence cream about 15 million that
about 40% of them are on 15 million not
working out of 43 million what what
ested this is taking what estimate would
you make how many what what number of
approximately 43 million on food stamps
do you think are not working according
to your numbers so that at least we can
clarify the factual dispute
so I think the the truth is that we have
two and a half million people today in
our economy who are on that TANF program
right so they are facing work
requirements and the truth is that the
TANF program has supported supports a
lot fewer people today than they sported
in the 1990s the case the TANF program
has been very good at lowering the
caseload for TANF it has been less good
as I noted earlier at eliminating
poverty poverty is at the same rate it
is I think the big fundamental question
is does a work requirement create a job
I do not think work requirements create
jobs I think people are looking for jobs
and have found a lot of jobs that don't
make ends meet that's why they are on
the Medicaid program the reason why we
have an expansion of Medicaid and
take-up of Medicaid is because fewer
employers at the lower income jobs offer
health insurance I do not think having a
work requirement for Medicaid is going
to make a difference in people trying to
select jobs because as we've just noted
they don't have income coming in we can
just argue out of nowhere with new facts
that they're in the underground economy
but we don't know that you're just made
we're just saying that as a supposition
but there's no data to say that these
lives people are working a lot of people
are facing a limited period of time
where they don't have a job and they're
still on food stamps we seem to have a
factual dispute about the Food Stamp
number but but actually you anticipated
my question and you know do you think do
you think the TANF program has been a
failure I guess you do or misconstruing
yeah I think if you if for those who
thought TANF would limit poverty with
would move people out of poverty it has
not moved people out of poverty the
poverty rate today is as high no I'm
sorry higher than it was before it we
eliminated AFDC do you think that did
you
the work requirement specifically of
TANF was a mistake I think that what we
should I think work requirements are
reasonable if you do take into account
recessions so I think there was a
significant problem with a with the TANF
program in that people hit their
lifetime limits at a time where we had
grave recession I think another
challenge with the TANF program is that
states have basically taken the money
that they were supposed to use on poor
people and used it for other programs
that have nothing to do with poor people
those those are two challenges two
fundamental challenges in the TANF
program but I believe if there are jobs
available as a principle people should
work the challenge is that the the
people are not finding work that pays
enough to make ends meet we do have I
mean the largest trend in poverty is not
people not working the largest trend in
poverty is with the working poor people
who are working 40 hours a week that is
a much larger number of people than
people who aren't working at all thank
you first question please phrase your
question as a question please tell us
who are you addressing it to if anybody
well hello uh Jean I know you like short
questions but I have the mic now I just
want to say yes we asked a question
quickly thank you for cultivating the
coolness intellectual hangout in New
York City I appreciate that
thank you you take a lot of time you
want sir exactly I I knew how to butter
you up Jean
okay so a Taryn enira I want to say
great points I appreciate that I want to
pose a question some of the question I
did at a previous debate you know the
relationships between people are
sophisticated between people and
governments and and peein families
within families so that being said I
just wonder if the methods that you guys
use and the data how often is it being
re-examined to see if it's still
relevant to see if it's true you guys
have had
cited studies offering different numbers
but I just wonder you know how often you
go back to these things because
ideological stances can be very rigid so
III just wonder if you guys can please
uh touch on this thank you sir I think
it's a great question the study that we
were involved in one oversaw a second
that we were involved in with following
60,000 Americans impacted by a work
requirement was done last year and I
think it's a great point we're looking
at doing follow-up tracking studies to
see exactly what happens with
individuals because I think success is
clear that anything that if you
individuals successfully move from
welfare to work and out of poverty that
success and to do so as quickly as
possible and we want to see what are the
best reforms that do that I think that
one of the things that's really key in
this whole conversation is it's not
enough to just want to work you also
need incentives and deadlines we all
respond that way and so the idea that
we're just going to hand out different
benefits whether it's Medicaid or food
stamps or cash assistance for
able-bodied adults with no criteria that
they work trained or volunteer I think
is just denying basic human behavior we
all respond to incentives and deadlines
so I just need to say this because we
keep going on to able-bodied adults
there are new Ebel bodied adults who get
TANF who get cash assistance who don't
have children the whole there's no
single guys out there getting TANF who
don't have kids right the everybody who
gets the TANF program today gets it with
children and if you don't have children
you don't get it and the reason we do
that is in our society we'd think kids
should not be punished for the decision
of their parents but yet there still is
a five-year limit on that on that number
so what we're really talking about again
is food stamps and Medicaid and we have
a fundamental just
about whether those incentives are
proper I think it's really I think you
raise an important issue which is going
back and really evaluating what's
happening I think there have been
criticisms of the Kansas study by as I
noted Republicans saying that it hasn't
actually had the impact but I think we
should look at Kansas for at large as an
example right Kansas is a state that did
the work requirements it is a state that
dramatically lowered taxes and said that
revenues would go up that is not been
true revenue did not go up in fact
revenue dramatically dropped and the
Republican legislature of Kansas just
voted to raise taxes to override the
governor's veto
there was an ideology that cash and what
work requirements would end poverty
poverty has not declined in Kansas even
though what work requirements were done
there I think we should actually look at
the Kansas example and say this is not
one that's working for the country
because the legislators in Kansas
actually looked at the evidence looked
at what happened in their state and
decided to go in the alternative
direction
we have two questions that Jim Epstein
is going to report from our vast global
audience
take the wait how about a $9,000 a year
universal basic income where everyone
gets $750 a month and phase-out Social
Security Medicaid Medicare food stamps
and pretty much all welfare $9,000 year
basic income and phase out all welfare
okay do you want to eject
and so I I I actually do not support
universal basic income because I believe
that that we should people who can work
should work if they can but also I think
there is a dignity to work I myself
would say we should have you know
obviously a little less libertarian than
the UVI supporters I think we should
support a minimum wage increase I think
we should think about investments we can
make in infrastructure in other areas
that can put people to work that is that
bipartisan support I worry that having a
ubi and is not does not is not a good
idea for community for people that's why
I said at the beginning of this you know
I think there is a dignity in work I
just think that we shouldn't make people
go hungry if they can't find a job just
a comment there are a number of
conservatives people call themselves
conservatives and even libertarians who
support a ubi
fascinating that near attend and opposes
it and just for the record wanted to
mention that do you want to comment sure
no I'm also opposed to it and it's
interesting this was on the ballot as a
referendum in Switzerland and it was
rejected with 80% of the vote I think
that what we can do is rather than blow
up the system and create something new
we can take principles and requirements
that work that move people from work or
from welfare to work as quickly as
possible and we can apply them to the
current program so we don't have to blow
up the whole system and just to follow
up on the point about Kansas but Kansas
has a right to change its taxes however
they want what's interesting is there
have been no changes to all the welfare
reforms and Kansas's work participation
rate is above the national average and
their child poverty rate is dropping
okay their work participation rate has
been high above the national average for
years I mean it didn't
a change with the work requirement so
it's always been very high it's been
higher since the work requirements went
into effect
at the end of 2013 okay our next
question so this one's just for Neera so
I'm sympathetic to your basically
arguing that the work requirements not
that meaningful but I have a question
for you about your alternative a minimum
wage so do you believe that a minimum
wage has any negative effects such as
reducing the total number of jobs and if
so can you talk about that yeah there's
I mean I think economists have looked at
this term multifaceted multi-use numbers
of economists who've looked at this and
I think the last CBO analyzed study most
recent data shows that you can get up to
eleven twelve dollars without a loss of
work the challenge there is I mean there
have been people who advocate even
higher the issue on a minimum wage
increase is that you are over there have
been studies about community states in
one state where they raise the minimum
wage versus another state where they
haven't what you've seen between those
two states in terms of job losses there
is obviously a rate at which you can
raise the minimum wage and there will be
job loss that is not that is not made up
by the fact that people are actually
have more income to buy products that is
the other side of this right people
raise prices of goods wages go up
they're able to buy more so there is a
number economists have said nationally
that number I mean there's a whole range
of economists but the most recent data
I've seen is shown
eleven twelve dollars an hour does not
have the negative impact overall in the
economy but you oppose a $15 no I think
that's I think we should really look at
that community by community in some
cities you can have I'm in Seattle
raised it to $15 has not seen the neck
consequences a lot of people claimed I
don't think you should have 15 and some
communities like you know like in rural
and rural parts of the rural communities
where that would create some more
pressure do you I don't want to comment
gen John I think we should have a
conversation about the minimum wage but
the fact is today in America there are
six and a half million open jobs so I
think before we have a debate about the
minimum wage let's think about how do we
move individuals who are able-bodied who
aren't working today into some of those
six and a half million open jobs so they
can start experiencing their own
American dream I think that I can just
say quickly about this is a question
about this this is a critical issue the
six million jobs in which we do not have
people working seventy percent of those
require high skills I absolutely agree
that we the number one priority for the
country should be trying to get people
into those jobs they take a skill level
that so many people who are turning in
and out of the labor force do not have
but I absolutely agree that would be a
high priority for us to ensure that
people have the skills for that work
it'd be almost like if you had a
requirement to work train and get those
skills or volunteer you might qualify
right but how do you get this is a this
is a great issue I'm all for that how
that who's providing the training
because that's what the limit has been
they haven't cost there's a cost of that
training that people don't have the
ability to pay themselves if you want to
if you want to subsidize that training
we can agree on that well I think you
made a great point about TANF funds
being available for that kind of
training and I think that absolutely
there's money that is already given to
governments that can be used for that
kind of trip this is a great example so
the federal government allocated money
to States for their caseload training
would have been a fantastic use of that
so would have so would have childcare
other issues that get people to work
seventy five percent of those dollars
have been used for
other things entirely right so that's
why there isn't resources to do training
and other things but if we can get
agreement for you to support federal
support for training I'm I can I can get
there really quickly then you'll jump on
board with Universal work requirements
on TANF which already exists
are you favor universal work requirement
for TANF okay I I wasn't doing so she
opposed it you favor it sounds like
we're reaching out there's some
dialectical agreement here next question
I actually had a very similar question
about minimum wage Karen so you know on
the one hand do you think that having a
higher minimum wage would incentivize
people to get off welfare and kind of
the flip side of that is if there is no
minimum wage and wages are low and you
could make nominally or marginally less
by staying on welfare it doesn't that
sort of incentivize you to just stand
welfare instead of working if you're
gonna be basically making the same thing
but you have to work 40 50 hours a week
I think that we have to be very careful
that we make the first step up the
economic ladder higher and higher
whether that's by adding occupational
licensing standards and making people go
through literally sometimes years of
training for jobs that they could maybe
apprentice and then move into I think
that the key is for individuals to move
from not working at all to work train or
volunteer get re-engaged back into the
community and I think that that is key
the best way to get a job is to have a
job and so even if somebody moves into
part-time work that person is much more
apt to then get a full-time job
the in the best way honestly to raise
the minimum wage is to have a strong
economy because then businesses have to
raise it to attract workers it was
driving by at McDonald's the other day
with my kids there's a hiring sign
minimum starting wage $13 an hour it's
higher than the state minimum wage but
as strong a common economy and a demand
for workers what we need to have is
reflect that demand
our welfare programs by saying to folks
this is a relationship work trainer
volunteer that's how you keep your
benefits but ultimately we want you out
of poverty that's success it's not
success to have these welfare programs
go faster and faster and the poverty
rate to remain unchanged as even narrow
admits and I think what's would I find
fascinating about this is you know we do
have facts here about the minimum wage
and other things minimum wage today has
the purchasing power of the minimum wage
in the 1960s it has not cut up kept up
and with inflation it does not have you
know would have I think the last study I
saw was that if the minimum wage kept up
with where it was when over the last 40
years it would be at $20 I'm not even
arguing for $20 but that just tells you
how much less purchasing power there is
in the minimum wage just to go to your
point we have four we have low
unemployment in the country very low
unemployment yet wages particularly for
the bottom have been stuck you know we
are not getting year over year over year
wage gains even though we are at four
and a half percent unemployment why
because unemployment is really 2 percent
if you've gone to college and seven and
a half percent if you haven't gone to
college we have a challenge which is
that work at the low end is not creating
economic mobility now I think the true
outrageous problem in the country is
that people would go hungry if it
weren't for food stamps and work 40 50
hours a week and I think that the way I
look at that is the federal government
is subsidizing private entities to not
give a living wage I don't know why we
don't look at it that way you know I
mean in other countries they manage to
solve these problems we should think
about creative ways to address that I do
not understand why people working many
hours and lis have to be on programs to
ensure their kids don't get poverty why
do we not ask why these work employers
don't provide health care our answer is
just don't have them health care
why don't we say employers why aren't
they covering this with health care
right we have a Medicaid program for
working poor people the vast majority as
I said of people on the Medicaid program
and the expansions are working poor
people that I think is a challenge we
should all think about next question
just two quick questions one do you both
support increasing the Earned Income Tax
Credit and to do you both support
government creating jobs like like the
WPA I get it in a new deal if you look
at the Earned Income Tax Credit today
almost any size family if you have one
person working full-time at a
minimum-wage job with the Earned Income
Tax Credit that family is out of poverty
and so I think that you have a strategy
that then rewards work in that area
particularly for parents and those with
kids as near admits we prioritize as a
country I think that that's a strategy
that's already in the tax code and it's
already available to people and insurers
that even if you're working in a minimum
wage job almost regardless of the size
of your family you're out of poverty
with that assistance so I think that's
in place right now
and that's a good thing there is no EITC
for childless adults but if they're
working full time and a minimum-wage job
they're out of poverty their incomes
above the poverty limit okay
so for anyone who so I think we need to
do
I would definitely support an AIT see
expansion which i think is definitely
work focused there are questions about
the EITC expansion for I mean the EITC
rates for families like yours with eight
kids and I think we should just say that
people who work full time shouldn't be
in poverty which is does not exist today
because the EITC does not guarantee that
as a as a matter of course for every
family but I I definitely think that
they should do that we should have the
EITC well there was a second
uh-oh back coming creating jobs New
Deal's Chuck yes so I you know I think
that jobs should be a focus you know
there areas like infrastructure which
Republicans and Democrats have supported
which aren't public jobs they're
basically the government you know
federal government puts up money and
supports private sector employment I
think we should think a lot more about
this those ideas in communities that
have had have had high unemployment for
a long time I think there there are
strategies and I think if you really
think work should be at the center of
your economic mobility strategy then I
think you should also think about
investing in areas where you'd put
people to work more directly just think
on that point certainly when you looked
at when the modern welfare state began
in the 1930s that's how they did it
individuals worked in those government
provided jobs but we even have examples
from today of that that can be a
successful strategy the mayor of
Milwaukee employed that strategy with
homeless in this their city guaranteed
that if you're homeless you have a job
at a maintenance job a lawn keeping kind
of job in Milwaukee the effect was a
dramatic reduction in homelessness
because it got people engaged in work
and then it made it made it easier for
them to move to another job so I think
it's an effective strategy right sorry I
the Q&A session is over those of you
still want to ask questions get a chance
to talk to the debaters after we adjourn
for the wine and the food chairing five
minutes of of summary please take them
take the Deponia
first I want to thank you all for a
lively and engaging evening on an
important topic in closing work is not a
punishment works an opportunity as I
mentioned work people who worked they
received so much more than a paycheck
people who work have better health and
better mental health higher rates of
happiness lower rates of depression
lower rates of smoking lower rates of
obesity and while we have this civil
debate in this theater when we leave
here today we'll be reminded of the
phases of dependency this isn't just a
debate though about government and
government policy now a few years ago
mentor asked me Taron what have you done
personally to engage in these things you
care about and debates don't count it
was a humbling moment for me so I
decided to do something about it because
I thought he really had a point let me
tell you about Levinson I had the chance
to meet this young man at a non-profit
and I helped start as a direct result of
this call to action to engage personally
our organization partners with churches
to host job fairs
in tough neighborhoods Levinson had been
fired from his last retail job for
accidentally leaving the door unlocked
we all make mistakes or forget things
but such a moment cost him his job
and being out of work made him spiral to
a dark place where he lost faith in
himself and his future and what Levinson
really needed was encouragement and
coaching he needed to sell himself and
to stand out in the crowd and our job
fair gave him that chance my coaching
helped prepped him and helped him answer
the tough questions that might come in
an interview and he got a job you know
people coming through the front door of
these job fairs may or may not be on
welfare but they all need so much more
than government alone can provide
another young woman Alicia was coached
at a different job fair she had a
criminal record and was on welfare and
took a job at the fair for her to see
that dependency didn't define her in
fact during her first six weeks on the
job ELISA was promoted twice and now her
criminal record and welfare are her past
and her future is bright you know this
isn't just about two people I'm proud to
stand here today to tell you that 8,000
people have walked through these job
fairs in just over a year and most get a
job and you know the biggest moment of
clarity for me a bell a staff member
created the opportunity bell which the
employer and the job seeker ring
together when that job seeker gets hired
on the spot and about 1 in 10 people do
and when that bell rings everyone in the
job fair stops and claps it's so
inspiring it's an incredible feeling and
to me it shows how important work is to
the human spirit and our goal in 2018 is
to serve 25,000 across the country from
LA to Washington DC from Waterville
Maine to Fort Myers Florida and I'd like
to personally invite everyone of you
here including you to come and join us
in person at one of these job fairs the
one thing we require is that you care
and believe in the human spirit look
this really isn't a debate it's a call
to action of what you should do what I
should do what business should do and
what government should not do to support
real opportunity for the millions of
Americans trapped on welfare and in
despair that man from Cuba I told you
about not only did he come here to start
a better life but he's transforming
every generation thereafter the truth is
that protecting the truly needy
something we all support requires that
those on welfare who can and should work
do so a strong safety net for the truly
needy is financed by a strong Amer
of those who should work doing so
including at least 15 million
able-bodied adults trapped on welfare
today thank you five minutes of summary
from you and your I take it away
thank you I guess not to say the
following which is I am see areas of
agreement you know I think we should
have policies to support and put to
support actual jobs and people who work
in and work full-time not being in
poverty I hope those are air at
principle as we can all agree with I
think that is ultimately what we have to
get to guess so concern I have is I'll
just walk through my own private my own
experience so I am a product of the
dreaded welfare state my parents got
divorced my father left my mother had
never worked and she went on welfare
section 8 housing food stamps every
program we're talking about faceless
bureaucrats somewhere decided to invest
in this program so when people are
harmed they have an opportunity I guess
what I'm saying to every person in this
room is that if my mother had a
challenge finding a job couldn't find
work or had some reason she didn't like
she had a problem I'm glad America never
said to me you go hungry you don't have
health care for those decisions I think
we have a fundamental challenge in this
country much bigger in numbers then the
people cycling in and out who don't have
a job we have millions of people who
work every day and can't make ends meet
they can't afford a health care on their
own that's why they use Medicaid they
can't feed their kids that what that's
why they use food stores and that's the
challenge that we have it's country that
I hope liberals and conservatives people
of goodwill
can tackle together thank you again
you'll see the post debate vote is
available to you
15 million able-bodied adults on
government welfare would have a better
chance at economic betterment if they
were taken off welfare please vote your
final decision
yes/no or undecided please vote to those
who are listening on streaming vote
yes/no undecided we are closing the
voting 15 million able-bodied adults on
government welfare would have a better
chance at economic sentiment if they
were taken off welfare
as I've said next month we're going to
have the debate between me and Yaron
Brook on selfishness and a great sequel
to this evening and he's going to be
talking about self is just being a
virtue I'm gonna take the negative and
February we're going to have a debate
about sex offenders the the sex
offenders you know have to go in a
registry and the proposition will be
that the registry should be abolished
and that will be a sizzling debate on
and March we're gonna have a debate
about the rape culture in April gonna
have to debate about about fractional
reserve banking in the Federal Reserve
being a threat to the stability of the
economy in June we're gonna have a
debate about constitutionalism the
originalist approach of Randy Barnett to
the Constitution will be defended in
July or we're gonna have a debate about
Bitcoin as you know if you go on our
website we sell discount packages so
that you can buy and reserve tickets
to a few of the debates so please come
again and I'm now looking at the voting
votes are still coming in on this issue
and I'll love give it to just give it a
just a minute more please stick around
up we are gonna have a party until 9
o'clock I trust our debaters gonna stick
around so that you can really bore in on
the topic we've just we've we've had an
intellectual marathon as all debates are
now comes the real in-depth discussion
that you're gonna have over a glass of
wine or a soft drink with nira or with
Taran and bear in mind of course that
this before and after voting is just a
game but always helps focus our mind on
what is on the issues and I'm gonna have
to wait another minute before I'm to
evoke so for the for the for the votes
to come in but right now I think I can
finally close the voting which I'm gonna
do okay well it was pretty close the yes
votes stood at 41% initially and picked
up 21 and a half percent but went up to
62 and a half percent so Taran picked up
nearly 22 points so that's the the
points to beat
Europe picked up nearly six points so
everybody won but so congratulations
denier but but Darren gets the tootsie
roll so congratulations to both of you
[Applause]
[Music]